[Music]
one of the things i'm petrified of back
to you asked me earlier is
i'm on every program here i'm going to
do it again i think
98 of the projects that are coming out
in nft form right now
are not going to be good investments 98.
[Applause]
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
gary vaynerchuk welcome to decrypt thank
you so much for having me dan
so nfts are the talk of the town i mean
we know that having covered every angle
of it
and that is your news is this nft launch
but before we even get into that
you know you've got such big following
on social obviously but i don't want to
assume that
everyone at decrypt and everyone among
our crypto readership
knows you yeah so there was wine library
there's vaynermedia
your content business what else do you
have going on right now in business
separate from crypto mainly i've been
had you know head down for the last
decade building a very large you know
agency
um which is pushing almost 1500 people
globally mexico city
singapore london the us been operating
you know
i do put out a lot of you know people
that are listening are aware of me it's
probably through the lens of the garyvee
content machine but
you know what i actually do in my
day-to-day is
i'm the ceo of a pretty large
service-based business that i've always
had long-term ambitions
to deploy against my activities two of
which i've already done
i launched resi the restaurant app seven
years ago we had a very successful exit
to mx and
three years ago i launched a direct
consumer wine brand called
empathy which we sold to constellation
brands
uh last year and so just on my business
journey you know doing my thing
let's talk about the nft launch there's
so much to get into there but
it is uh v friends right and as we talk
you are
just about to kind of pull the trigger
on that talk to us about
what went into it i mean everyone right
now is launching nfts in some form but
some projects compared to other varying
levels of quality some of this stuff
looks a little bit
fly by night you know jumping on the
bandwagon what did you
try to do and what's your aim in terms
of your own series
so for me i i agree with you i think
you know this reminds me so much because
i was there of
internet startup life 99 you know
such a there's such an opportunity for a
land grab cash grab
and you have seen people with large
audiences
um come out with you know
commissioned a digital artist put their
name on it and
have you know extracted a lot of dollars
from their fan base and i think the con
cern i have there is it's a nice
short-term transaction if that's what
your goal is
but i think if you leave a fan base
holding the bag
you know that can't work out in the long
term and so for me
i walked in very eyes wide open knowing
that you know
in the in the beginning of this year i'm
like oh my god i'm going to do this
this is a real thing you know and i've
been you know i was an investor in
ethereum back in 17
pretty actively i'd been watching the
space for a while but much like
everything i do including what i'm doing
with the vr now i'm taking meetings i'm
watching the new oculus stuff i'm
looking at startups
but i won't put out a lot of content on
it because i don't want to
say things that end up being wrong
because that's hurt your reputation and
so
you know for all my gapping i do quite a
bit of listening and thinking before i
start yapping heavily
and so i felt it was time i felt you
know i i got
very deep in to investing in crypto
punks
and because i just truly believe that it
was good investment as you can see
sports cards comic books toys i i it
comes natural to me it's something i've
always done
even wine i think the reason i had a
good wine career was because people
collect wine it's just a place i play
and i really you know i wanted to invest
more into space i want to
expand my business activities and the
only thing i know is
when i see a game changer i need to get
my hands dirty and when i saw a
game-changer of the internet i launched
a website when i didn't even dan i
didn't even know in a computer when i
launched winelibrary.com
that's how quickly i moved that knowing
the internet was gonna be big
but wasn't in it yet uh even social like
the whole garyvee stuff
if you know i was 30 years old before i
put out a piece of content on the
internet it wasn't really my
ambition to be known i just knew that we
were upon this web 2.0 era where
first you know personal content i
started with wine right what i knew
and then i went into you know you know
business stuff and so i knew that i
needed to
get my hands dirty and so i spent months
really thinking through
a couple things one i thought it was an
opportunity to show that nfts had smart
contracts underneath them
i think everyone's forgotten that with
the beeple craze and with the top shot
craze and we've become very art and
collectible
and i said you know let me let me a
it was actually just a conversion of
many things south by southwest changed
my life it's where i met some of the
smartest people kindest people
and i always said to myself after south
by 2008 which was my third south by
one day i want to throw a conference
like this like something big
so that's always been in my mind so for
me putting out this befriends project
where every token all 10
255 is also a three-year ticket to vcon
a conference that i want to put on
that's a mix i would say of
davos south by i would say a little of
like
pop culture like maybe there's some
music maybe actually
summer camp i want to have a lot of
confidence like i want people like
doing some competition because i like
that anyway
that was big and then you know facetime
hangout groups some access you know my
dream when i was
baking it was oh if novak djokovic
follows this model
instead of somebody just making a
painting of him and i can
buy a token that gives me a hitting
session with him
or if i can go into studio with the
weekend you know
kind of thought of it from that
perspective um and so
yeah i'm really that's what i wanted to
do do off-chain
you know realities in smart contract and
then finally
you know i started vaynermedia with the
intent to buy
nostalgic brands in ip and
that's what i thought i was up to
literally up to even 18 months ago
and then this momentum of the center t
space i firmly believe
that two or three of the most
significant intellectual
property pop in pop culture in 20 years
the the hello kitties the pokemons
the harry potters i believe like video
games
and card games and movies and books
were platforms for much bigger expansion
of that
ip i believe that nft's destiny is
definitely to groom
and to spring up three to five
meaningful intellectual properties
and i have substantial ambition for v
friends to be one of them
there's a lot there uh you mentioned
some of this is right now a land grab or
at least a cash grab
and i say the same thing that the wheat
will be separated from the chaff
you know in other words there's going to
be a shaking out some of the nfts that
are being launched right now
are fly by night quick it's tied to a
brand or a celebrity and it's to make a
quick buck and then you're out you did
it
other things will survive and thrive and
and remain and look legit it's the same
thing as the ico boom
you know ico has become a dirty word but
some of those tokens that were launched
during that time
have remained and have proven themselves
legitimate and have real companies or
use cases behind them
many of them were not so all that said
did you have any kind of concerns before
announcing this
that some people would frame this you
know in terms of the snarky
uh another nft thing just to say
of course i do i i have a very loud
personality that comes with everything i
do it's this
it's a continuous story of my life as a
matter of fact
i've had a really nice business career
where i've you know things like empathy
and residue are just not even
conversated about
you know of course when somebody's
positioned as loud or motivational
speaker like
i'm the least like naive to what the
narrative is
what has worked for me dan but that
happened with me with winelibrary.com
long before a human knew who i was all
my dad's friends made fun of him for
letting his son
do this stupid internet thing right or
or when i started the youtube show
i was at the height of building one of
the largest ecommerce wine businesses in
america people literally
around me and definitely outside of me
thought i'd lost my mind right like
that i was like loopy like what is this
youtube thing so
yeah i do worry about that and i i i
don't know what to do other than
execute over the next decade to like
have that thought out you know i think
we live in a world where whether it's a
social media comment or
a podcast or an article written you're
you're going gonna get that and i'm
definitely gonna get that with the way
that i communicate and i
it you know it doesn't feel great
especially when you feel like you're
truly legitimate and really done stuff
your whole life
but i think it would be very unfair for
me not to recognize that
my over-the-top natural dna energy as a
communicator
that that comes you know there's a lot
of good things that come along with it
people get excited and opportunities
happen but
that is part of the baggage that comes
along with it there's plenty of times
that i'm like man
if i just had 25 percent less of that
then i would you know then the crescendo
it would be like pitch perfect but
that's not the case and i don't i don't
dwell on that
i think what i have to do is spend the
next
you know two three decades putting out a
meaningful children's book a toy
an animated series a playing card you
know things to develop these characters
then that's why i went with that route
this is not you know to me dan to be
frank
this is a real relief and maybe the
starting point of the things that i care
about patience
ambition kindness candor like the things
i talk about
i've had to be the vehicle which comes
with all that baggage
now i'm going to be able to put things
that i believe in empathy and other
things into the world
through these characters that are really
driven by gratitude of my circumstance
and so
i'm actually genuinely excited about the
character development because i think
it's going to take a lot of
the onus off of me the human to maybe
put these things that i want to put into
the world
yeah creating a whole series of
characters and thinking of different
outlets for them reminds me a little bit
of what marty bennett is up to you know
martellus bennett
the former nfl player uh interviewed him
a while back and he's really trying to
create like his own version of a disney
that's
interesting yeah i think and i think you
will see
many many many people like i i would
call it like influencer marketing right
i don't think martellus and i are like
we're gonna be two of
hundreds of thousands and i think like
influencer marketing they'll be
you know a top one percent that actually
had the talent to create a
despicable me or you know uh you know a
get along gang or smurfs or scooby-doo
or
right tom and jerry but i think unlike
the history of television and film
you're going to find a lot of micro
ip you're going to find a lot of
mid-market really solid
you know the human behind it sustains a
lifestyle maybe
it's a six figure you know a year life
but it's
so much cooler than what they were doing
otherwise they've turned their art and
their story
you know you don't need it to hit on on
the morning
cartoon or at the bookshelf or on
netflix you don't need it to go smashing
you can you can have a nice solid thing
and i think
that was something i talked a lot about
with influencer marketing that the long
tail was much longer than people
realized
and that is actually my prediction for
what's going to happen with ip
development
look i i do have a lot of confidence and
hopes and dreams and i want to
smash it but you know if it ends up
being a mid-tier play it's still really
cool and you still
get those creative juices out i think a
lot of people's destinies are going to
be there
well and another thing especially in the
crypto world as we know you look at some
of the projects that are
the biggest even something like crypto
punks which they're selling for so much
money because they're the ogs
it's still so unknown to a vast
part of the population i mean you can
have something
90 90 99
that's what's so cool i'm sure for you
right you going through
you know you guys have this incredible
show and you know already you have
momentum
and you're like [ __ ] nobody even knows
yet
right and by the way i've been there
twice i really was i was there with 96
and seven with dot com i'm like oh my
god
you know because what you know what i
know is you
start tasting it and you're like man
this is doing pretty well wait a minute
nobody knows yet this could be cool
same for you know social media i was
like wait a minute everybody's doing
this at a certain age
and and that's what actually has me
extremely bullish on nfts i don't think
people realize
we have an entire generation of under 18
year olds
who are so matter-of-fact on nfts
because of roblox
because of skins on fortnight like they
don't even
think twice and then i remember you know
i remind a lot of my 40 year old friends
i'm like
bro you bought sheep on farmville
you know like like simcity i mean any
things that had in-game
purchases absolutely correct i'm like
now
the whole world's the game and the plus
ups are interchangeable when you got
bored with minecraft and you graduate
to you know uh fortnite you're kind of
stuck in the four walls
of minecraft these now become on a
blockchain world
interchangeable assets you're gonna be
able to trade in
you know you know what's so funny dan i
i'm such a big garage sailor i don't
know if you know this about me but like
i'm obsessed with garage sailing
and i see this every day i like roll up
on a home and i see the 13 year old and
sure enough
all the toys that are for sale are from
when that with kid was seven
and they're trading to the next thing
but they're selling those things for
eight
cents in a bag instead of 12 bucks a
piece that they paid for those
skylanders
in in nft land there's gonna be a very
different dynamic there
and that's gonna be an interesting thing
to watch as a collector and trader and
it's kind of neat i'm excited to see a
mature nft space of interchangeable
assets
well i'm glad you mentioned you know
friends in your peer group and you try
to explain it to them because my next
question was going to be
there are people right now probably
actually most people
who just can't really wrap their minds
around it and i totally understand that
and i don't blame them
you know i spoke to mark cuban a few
months ago and he just said people need
to get past the mental hurdle
of physical ownership of thinking you
have to be able to physically display it
just understand
that value has gone digital ownership
has gone digital
all that is fine but even once you
explain that there's a lot of people and
they still just say
i just can't see paying 70 million
dollars well digital image
look that's no different than what i was
telling all my buddies in 1999 that
everybody was going to date through the
internet and they were like no way i'm
not a fat dude in my mom's basement and
i'm like
no no you're not understanding the
convenience
and the cultural shifts i didn't use
such smart words
back then but like you know like it was
just very obvious to me and so for me
the public wallet
as a communication tool no different
than what you've got on your shelf there
with the dog and
no matter what i got and how you wear
your facial hair and what shirt you're
wearing and like
humans communicate and to to mark's
credit that's exactly right i don't even
live in my mind anymore
without the public wallet being as
important as a google result or an
instagram lookup when you meet someone
new
well and let me push you on that because
there's still an amount of friction i
mean we can
divide up and it depends which nft site
you're talking about
like top shot i think has gone
mainstream because it allows dollars
that's fine
but also people can use and enjoy that
without even really ever understanding
crypto whereas
some of the other nft sites you need to
own
some eth so you need to go to an
exchange buy some ether
have a metamask wallet go back to the
nft site
plug in your metamask wallet pay in eth
and i still think that
that's a lot of steps for people who are
not crypto native
i mean do you think they couldn't
ideally friction reduction
i think they're going to happen two ways
i think you know the bitsky's the
you know flows they're doing a great job
with fiat for me
i was willing for this to do less well
to then show a big community of mine and
others
how to actually taste it for the first
time for me dan
that's very authentic because in 1997
and 1998 and 1999
i spent the majority of my time standing
in a liquor store for 12 hours a day
talking to people and saying no no
i'm telling you your credit card will
not be stolen if you buy
stuff on you don't have to drive six
hours to our good wine store like um
thank you but
we can ship this to you and you know you
may remember this you know just
rough guessing on your age your parents
or maybe your friend's parents like
people were scared to put their credit
card into the internet
and you know bro and i'm empathetic to
everybody the first time i bought
something with a meta mask in my chrome
browser and it had that 30 second delay
i was like
i was like did i you know i was like
scared shitless i'm like and it was five
minutes that was
five months ago so i i
think that it will happen inevitably i
genuinely believe two things will happen
people will get more comfortable and i
think look at rainbow's wallet
versus metamask right rainbow displays
it in such a consumer-facing way
and i think you know this and i know
this and many who are listening if
they're listening to the show they know
this
that in 24 months the technology and the
web 3-0 gang will make it better
and the audience will get there sooner
and they're going to meet somewhere in
the middle
and you know i'm going to look back at
what i paid in gas fees to mint my
project and throw up just like i think
about
what i paid in server costs for early
wine library compared to what aws
now does so this is just you know what's
fun about getting the gray hairs and
starting to lose it
is you get really good pattern
recognition right
and web one for me was intuitive web 2
was
affirmation web 3 for me is
flag in the ground like oh i've seen
this movie multiple times i'm
moonwalking through this
chapter no pun intended with moon
yes let me ask you we have to hit on
this
and again it speaks to when something is
starting to get mainstream
you get a lot of chatter and and maybe
people have some misconceptions but
the environmental concerns yeah out to
the corner people say
there are people say i've heard they're
bad for the environment now they haven't
necessarily read so much about them and
of course the truth is we're talking
about is mining on ethereum
and yes it uses a lot of electricity but
ethereum is in the process of moving
to proof of stake and that won't use as
much electricity but without getting
into the weeds on the technics of it
have you already seen some of that
pushback from people who are your fans
who say
oh i thought these things are killing
the environment what do you say to
offset that
uh i you know as i was like okay you
know ethereum
was what i was most comfortable with
when i was really saying i'm gonna do
this
so you know i would never do something
that i'm not comfortable with
i just wouldn't do it right i was like
i'm going to do this on eve
and to your point i i you know where's
my report card there's a reason i got
f's you know you're not going to be able
to see this but there's a real reason
why i got a bunch of f's in science like
i really struggle with it what i what i
definitely got to a place of is like
okay i understand
proof of stake i understand what l2 is
bringing to the equation
um the thing that was really interesting
for my project dan was
this project these characters were two
years ago
i was making a toy project called
workplace warriors
same characters to sit in people's you
know back to the way i like to roll
right
um so one of the things i've been very
fascinated by
is the net impact right i'm a sports
card collector
it's a lot of cardboard a lot of plastic
a lot of shipping a lot of fedex a lot
of ups a lot of cardboard
so you know my intuition
is over time it should be a winner
compared to all the
plastic and paper and and
fuel that's used to schlep around
physical goods
um obviously eth has clearly made a
sticking around and then you as i don't
have to explain to this audience
there's incredible amounts of pla
blockchain standing up
that you know are dramatically less uh
reliant on proof of work including youth
itself so
a little bit but it's funny to watch
that conversation i think people
you know to a lot of people's credit i
think people hear that
and they are concerned about that
because it's an important issue but i
think people are
educating themselves more and more i i
watch this very daily and i
i look you know this it's like any
subject matter in the world
some people are just going to draw a
line in the sand and there's it's like
politics or anything else
there is no conversation but i watched
very carefully people
um by the way both ways both ways
people were like [ __ ] you this is my and
kind of go to mill and people were like
and say you know what yeah and and you
know what that's nice i've seen a lot of
you
you know the word i would use is i've
seen a lot of humanity from both sides
of the conversation of like
of like realizing there's there's a lot
of nuances
and and i think very good you know
steps in the direction of trying to
address it because it's an important one
yeah absolutely i mean what i like to
say gary is that there are some people
who just
they never want anything to do with it
they've decided it's stupid and that's
fine
but i think what has changed within the
last year or year and a half is that at
the very least
those people can now acknowledge even if
you have no interest in the whole crypto
world and you don't want to touch it
fine
but you acknowledge that it's real it
exists it is here to stay
you know skeptics used to say what if it
all collapses bitcoin could crash to
zero
it's not going to go to zero that has
never happened and it has proven itself
after 11 years
and these two things i think bitcoin and
ethereum at the very least
they have staying power you know whether
you want to touch it and be involved
with it
up to you yeah it's you know one of the
things i'm petrified of back to you
asked me earlier is
i'm on every program here i'm going to
do it again i think 98
of the projects that are coming out in
nft form right now are not going to be
good investments
98. comma
i think the nft macro technology is one
of the most significant things to happen
in the last 25 years at the consumer
behavior level you know from you know so
you know
the all these things are incredibly
nuanced
to your point right like like you know
to me
i'm an incredibly big enthusiast of the
bitcoin
universe people i've done some podcasts
and people feel like
i'm anti and i'm like no no i think it's
so big that i'm curious what sovereign
nations are gonna do i'm like
i'm like kind of weirdly more bullish
i'm like no no this is
really here to to stay comma what's
gonna hap like
do governments fear it like i actually
like that's fascinating to me of like
you know if if if sovereign nations lose
leverage
of you know of of currency that's
powerful combos so
you know it's it's a very nuanced thing
and like that's why
headlines are so dangerous for all of us
it's why i kind of stay out of most
subject matters now i realize
in 99 of subject matters i'm a headline
reader
right you've got passing thoughts of
somebody you think is smart on it or
things that nature and
you know for me this is deja vu this is
web 2.
every single conversation around twitter
and facebook in 2007 to me looked like
the following gary facebook's just for
kids it's just college kids
trying to put up beer pong photos and
twitter was this is the
stupidest thing i've ever heard who
gives a [ __ ] if you're going to eat a
pizza
why would somebody share that and so
that's what people say to me about
twitter
i still have friends who just don't use
twitter and i'm always like you
why don't you i just find it so useful
for news gathering and they say because
i don't need to know whatever i need for
lunch and i just
that's not what it is anymore you know
right it's you know and that's
fine listen i think there's people in
the know business i think there's people
in the yes business
i think there's people in the optimistic
practical business i think there's
people in the cynicism business
you know there's a lot of human traits
out there and i think people show their
cards and their actions and
you know i think for me i um
i have a natural tendency to get
uncomfortably excited
and loud when i know something which
comes with a lot of
potential baggage and i think for me and
i think for everybody who's listening
who's bullish and believes the nice
thing is you don't have to convince
people you just have to execute
you know like you know for me execution
always is the final judger not
my conviction of myself not the cynicism
on the other side or the act or the
cheering at this point in my career i
have plenty of cheering
and i think that's very dangerous i
think once you hear the cheering
you become susceptible to getting very
confused i think
humility and self-awareness are the
foundations of actually pulling off a
lot of these things
uh just a couple more for you gary you
know especially the environmental stuff
as far as i see it the other main if
there's kind of two main
i guess uh concerns or criticisms of the
whole
boom is starting to realize well
what is it you even really own i mean it
depends on
the nft site you're using but some of
them aren't always storing things on
chain
uh some of them in some cases you're
really just buying
an address right you know as people who
don't understand it frame it you're
paying for a url but you're buying an
address
that represents something somewhere else
and so people say you're paying all this
money what are you really getting and
what can you do with it well you can
share it
and say check this out i own this thing
which is cool or you can flip it you can
sell it
so in your case with your entities as
you mentioned they also come with
passes to future in-person events and
what i push you on is
all the people who believe in nfts the
way they frame it is just wrap your mind
around digital only it's all about
digital
and then you add there's also this
in-person event you're going to get a
pass to does that
detract from the whole thing at all i
mean is that just see
is there any way that that's just and
we'll throw this in
you know it's a cell
you know for me the way i read it i i
haven't really
spelt that take you know i for me
i think the smart contracts the most
interesting part
of nfts from the standpoint of i expect
to nft my
future homes you know like and transact
i mean it like i mean i don't see why
it's a it's a very clean decentralized
ledger i think
people are incredibly i think people's
marriage certificates are gonna be on it
right like
like why not like it's a very very clear
clean decentralized ledger that i think
people going to really build momentum on
so
i you know for me i actually thought
that was the i was very passionate about
that part with my project
that was kind of like all the
ingredients of like i've always wanted
to throw this conference oh i've always
wanted to buy
the smurfs but wait a minute maybe i can
create yeah you know
there are probably people who want nfts
to stay narrow
in art and collectibilities i think that
would be
you know i always find it funny when
people are mad i'll give you an example
i was in a lot of clubhouses in in
january
in february march talking about like
watching people from the
physical art world [ __ ] on nfts and i
was like
i was like but you're a contemporary
artist and just 50 years ago your art
wasn't considered art why are you doing
this to these nft artists
and then some of those nft artists were
like my
when they saw my doodles were like
that's not art gary you're just trying
to trade on your
fame and i'm like wait a minute you
literally
40 days ago were fighting for the right
to call your thing art and now
you know i find that interesting and so
i think
i think it's very dangerous to impose
what one wants something to be
without understanding all the different
use cases something can be
so for to me the one of the neatest part
is the contract and i think i can't wait
to see innovators
come up with things that aren't even
running through my mind yet
you know i'm excited to go to i'll give
you an example then as you know i'm a
very big jets fan
i was at the monday night miracle right
i was at that game
and i you know and as a jets fan
i'm sure this is very nerdy for people
they were losing 30 to seven to the
dolphins with like 12 minutes to go and
they came back and won it was
ludicrous the monday night miracle there
was only like 4 000 people left in the
stadium dan cause everybody left because
it was a monday night game
my cousin bobby left at halftime when i
called him saying can you believe we're
almost coming back
he was already sleeping in queens that's
how
like he left that long ago i
there was five six thousand people left
in that stadium for that game
i personally have met twenty thousand
people that claim they were there
i when i started understanding what nfts
could do i was like man
one day i'll be my ticket will be in nft
because it
should and will be but they'll probably
be nft
readers that i could scan on the way out
to prove that i stayed for the whole
thing and then on the blockchain they're
like no no
there were 4 329 people
who stayed for it so like i just think
uh provenance and all that is really
important
and i think the counterfeit world the
hearsay world
that you don't really know world like a
lot of great things will happen
in our society and other things will
happen in a different way like you know
there's always a counter
there was all these blessings that came
with social that i saw in 2007 eight
nine that were incredibly beautiful
and then there's you know silos and
bullying and all sorts
of other things and there are plenty
things that people are going to be
uncomfortable with as blockchain becomes
fully scaled but they're going to be
some incredible good things and i'm
excited for that chapter dan
absolutely uh it's it's a fair and good
answer
let's end on this so to circle back to
the nft series
v friends what will success here
look like to you you know i know you're
not just measuring in terms of
how much do these things sell for how
hot are they how will you measure
whether your
foray into nfts has been a success
uh two ways short term the projects that
come out this fall from people that
have the luxurious situation that i have
which is a large audience
are dramatically more thoughtful for the
people on the other side of the
transaction than the person
that issued it for me personally
that in 18 years
there'll be conversations over dinner
with me and acquaintances or friends or
maybe i run into
with you and say man remember we talked
right before
you know you know you know i have a very
good memory like i can literally see you
and i in atlantic city talking
the last time several you like right and
so for me
to truly answer this for me success is
only if i'm able to execute over the
next several decades
to build a truly truly meaningful and
i'm talking i'm shooting for like
scooby-doo smurfs that's big
big big and i really think i can and
i'll be honest with you it's similar to
the jets i realized
i'm like why do i love this so much
trying to make v
friends a cultural intellectual property
trying just like trying to buy the jets
is like so fun for me it's it's built
out of curiosity
chess do i have it can i
it's like it's fun so to me success will
be that i went out and actually did it
and
became one of the few and definitely one
of the first
to stand up a meaningful pop culture
intellectual property from the ground of
an nft platform the way angry birds did
from an iphone game the way that
pokemon did from a card game the way
that harry potter did from a book
awesome yeah i agree by the way with the
in-game comparisons i think that's one
way to frame all this that
has been a little bit lost that a lot
more people can understand you know
i even mentioned kim kardashian k coins
i think that's
an early analogy that makes a lot of
sense you know people who asked mom and
dad for the credit card to buy
rewards in that game same kind of 100
i mean we're gonna have a lot we're
gonna have a lot of things that are
gonna make people uncomfortable people
are gonna sell
shares of their future earnings there's
gonna be a lot of things that are gonna
happen and i remind people
especially if you're listening to this
podcast by nature
you're more innovative you're more
open-minded you're more curious
like who's listening right now to this
right you are that person
no is a very different answer than
let me think this through and then have
an opinion
and that in that delta because trust me
and you see it dan and i think you have
a good radar for this
there's a lot of things that are not
exciting about how humans are gonna
are acting right now with this gold rush
it was one of the reasons i was excited
to stand up this project
i feel like i could create a framework
that
could be replicated in a better way and
i think you know
but but don't let the very minimal
percentage
of people that are bad and looking for
very selfish greed
moves cloud you in the macro of so much
good
and i think our society has a lot of
fear based in it right like
one you know one person has a bad
situation at a mall because of myspace
and then the news pumps it and then
people didn't want you know like that
kind of stuff right so like you know i
think there's a lot of good here and i
think there's incredible humanity i've
met so many people in the community ogs
in the nft space in the crypto space and
just creative
curious thoughtful smart innovative
like there's just so much stuff that you
can't even imagine is about to happen
next 10 years and
being close to it is a huge mistake if
you plan on living in the world
i like to say gary the tech is agnostic
so you can point to use cases you don't
like you can point to crime you know
hackers
asking for ransom and bitcoin or you can
point to the social good and the
examples of helping people
the tech itself is agnostic i think
that's right dan
i really genuinely do and i think the
tech is the blockchain
and all these blockchains that are
popping up is
the as big of an innovation
to our lives as the internet was as the
printing press was
and all of us will be integrating into
that reality for the rest of our
collective lives
and the quicker we get thoughtful with
it instead of dismissive or by the way
blindly
ambitious the other way like you've got
to find that equilibrium
and um you know i i'm speaking with
massive hyperbole the smurfs and
scooby-doo are some of the biggest
intellectual properties of all time but
it doesn't temper my ambition
and my enthusiasm on the flip side i am
far from confused
after my 20 years of operating how much
work how much effort
how many really smart decisions i have
to make to even begin to sniff
that level of success but i'm up for and
i'm excited to see and if not
i'll be the first to be like look i
didn't have it we'll just have to talk
again in 20 years
and see where the nft space is i'd like
that dan i wish you a lot of success
congrats on this
youtube bachelor what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you